ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen per
Fernsehansprache hat russlands Präsident
Putin heute deutliche Worte an sein
landgerichtet aber auch an die ganze
Welt Tenor Russland macht mobil genauer
gesagt geht es um eine teilmobil-machung
von rund 300.000 Reservisten ist die
Rede die eingezogen werden sollen um so
sagt es Präsident Putin ihr Heimatland
zu verteidigen dabei wolle man notfalls
alle zur Verfügung stehenden Mittel
einsetzen der Westen habe mit seiner
aggressiven anti-russischen Politik alle
Grenzen überschritten so Putin weiter
was bedeutet das alles warum hat Putin
sich für diesen Schritt entschieden und
welche Folgen ergeben sich daraus das
sind nur einige Fragen die wir heute
besprechen wollen und zwar mit dem
Militärexperten Wolfgang Richter einem
Oberst ad und davor mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler Nico lange eure
Fragen wie immer gerne an uns per Mail
oder über unsere Social Media Kanäle und
zuallererst gibt uns Sebastian eben noch
mal einen Überblick über die Ereignisse
des Tages
in den russischen Nachrichtensendungen
gibt es heute nur ein Thema die
Fernsehansprache von Präsident Wladimir
Putin die Botschaft die der Kreml heute
an sein Volk sendet ist ein Paukenschlag
und wird das Leben 10.000er Russen
verändern
wir wollen die Sicherheit unserer
Bevölkerung und der in den befreiten
Gebieten gewährleisten deswegen halte
ich es für notwendig den Vorschlag
unseres
Verteidigungsministeriums und der
Generäle zu unterstützen und eine
Teilmobilmachung in der Russischen
Föderation einzuleiten
einen entsprechenden Erlass habe er
bereits unterzeichnet dieser trete heute
in Kraft gegen die Bekanntmachung
formiert sich Protest in Russland hier
in Novosibirsk gehen die Menschen auf
die Straße bis die Polizei rigoros
einschreitet es gibt Festnahmen ähnliche
Bilder in Tomsk und jekaterinnenburg in
Moskau selbst ist die Meinung am Morgen
geteilt
ich habe fünf Söhne ich möchte nicht
dass sie in den Krieg gehen
augenscheinlich reichen die Ressourcen
nicht aus es werden Leute gebraucht die
müssen das ja irgendwie beenden
in diesen von Russland besetzten
Gebieten sollen ab Freitag
Volksabstimmungen über einen Anschluss
an Russland abgehalten werden dass dort
freie Willensbildung und faire
Abstimmungen möglich sein werden gilt
als ausgeschlossen und genau dort sowie
an der 1.000 km langen Front sollen auch
die einberufenen Reservisten zum Einsatz
kommen wie so häufig drohte Vladimir
Putin heute in seiner Ansprache auch dem
Westen
die russischen Bürger können sich sicher
sein dass die territoriale Integrität
unseres Heimatlandes gesichert und
unsere Unabhängigkeit und Freiheit
gewährleistet ist das will ich noch
einmal betonen und zwar mit all den uns
zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln
diejenigen die versuchen uns mit
Nuklearwaffen zu erpressen sollten
wissen der Wind kann sich schnell drehen
aktuelle Bilder von der
finnisch-russischen Grenze zeigen lange
Staus bei der Ausreise und zur Stunde
diese Aufnahmen aus Moskau Protest auch
in der Hauptstadt und auch hier
schreitet die Polizei sofort ein
und wir sprechen mit Nico lange Politik
Wissenschaftler aber auch Publizist und
Politikberater Experte für Russland und
die Ukraine er hat wenn ich es richtig
recherchiert habe sechs Jahre für die
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung in der Ukraine
gearbeitet und auch in St Petersburg
lebt schönen Abend schön dass Sie da
sind hallo
guten Abend
erste Frage gleich von uns anlässlich
der aktuellen Bilder die wir gerade
gesehen haben uns erreichen immer mehr
Bilder von Protesten und Festnahmen
mehrere hundert sollen es schon sein aus
Moskau Jekaterinburg und Toms gegen die
teilmobilenmachung unser Korrespondent
hat gerade auch noch mal aus Moskau
berichtet dass er so ein hartes
Einschreiten der Sicherheitskräfte noch
nicht erlebt hat bislang kann es also
sein dass Putin mit dieser
Teilmobilmachung das Volk gegen sich
aufbringt wie schätzen Sie das ein
der putin hatte ja gute Gründe warum er
die Mobilmachung peinliches vermieden
hat seit er den Krieg begonnen hat er
wusste dass es so eine Art stilles
Abkommen geben kann mit den russischen
Bürgern wenn er den Krieg führt aber
dafür vor allen Dingen Soldaten aus
entlegenen Provinzen einsetzt und die
Bürger in den großen Städten im großen
Ganzen in Ruhe lässt dann hat er
Unterstützung für diesen Krieg und er
hat das sehr lange vermieden über mobil
machen zu reden oder eine Mobilmachung
auszulösen und dass er das jetzt tun
musste ist einerseits ein Zeichen der
Schwäche beim militärisch die Dinge sich
nicht so entwickeln wie er sich das
vorgestellt hat vor allen Dingen aber
ist es jetzt etwas was in der russischen
Gesellschaft ankommt und wo er wusste
dass das zu Protesten führen wird und
dass das auch zu Widerständen führen
wird und genau das sehen wir jetzt dass
wenn wir gleich noch vertiefen dieser
Aspekte wir wollen gerade noch eine
weitere Stimme hören auch der Kreml
denke Alexa wallny hat sich heute zu
Wort gemeldet im Rahmen seiner
Gerichtsverhandlung und da wollen wir
gerade auch noch mal reinhören
es ist schon jetzt klar dass dieses
Verbrechen dass dieser kriminelle Krieg
schlimmer wird intensiver und Putin
versucht so viele wie nur irgend möglich
hineinzuziehen
um seine eigene Macht zu verlängern
zerfleischt er das Nachbarland tötet
dort Menschen und jetzt wirft er noch
eine riesige Zahl an russischen Bürgern
in den Fleischwolf nicht vor weil sie
ist gegriffen
tja drastische Worte von Alexej na weini
das dürfte in Russland bislang
vielleicht noch eine Mindermeinung sein
aber mit der mobil machen wird der Krieg
natürlich auch irgendwie immer weiter in
die Bevölkerung hineingetragen er wird
dichter er rückt näher an die Menschen
heran insbesondere dann natürlich wenn
dann auch die Todeszahlen steigen
sollten wie problematisch kann das für
Putin werden
wenn die Lage ist doch ehrlich gesagt
jetzt schon problematisch der Krieg von
dem er behauptet hat der sei gar kein
Krieg und er würde nicht mal sechs Tage
dauern dauert jetzt schon über sechs
Monate und die angeblich so stark und
überlegende russische Armee ist jetzt
ins Hintertreffen geraten es gibt
erfolgreiche Gegenangriffe der Ukrainer
und er muss jetzt die Mobilmachung
ausrufen aber auch verzweifelt über kurz
oder lang diese angeblichen Referenten
einen berufen um die Eroberung
abzusichern weil er Angst hat noch
weiter ins Hintertreffen zu kommen also
Putin hat schon erhebliche Probleme und
meiner Meinung nach hat er mit der
Mobilmachung und mit den Erklärungen von
heute die ja auch auf komischerweise
zustande kamen gestern verschoben worden
sind hatte zu seinen weiteren Problemen
noch beigetragen das wird seine Lage
nicht verbessern
wir lesen mal ein paar oder ich mache
das besser gesagt Kommentare auf Youtube
vor Schluckauf sagt dann muss Putin ja
mal endlich zugeben dass er einen Krieg
führt ich kann einfach nicht fassen dass
er ein Volk dabei mitmacht ähnlich der
Kommentar auf der heute Homepage von
venlohr Putin ist in der Defensive er
versucht nach wie vor der russischen
Bevölkerung den Krieg als
spezialoperation zu verkaufen das wird
ihm zunehmend nicht mehr gelingen ja
bleiben wir gerade vielleicht noch mal
dabei bei den innenpolitischen Problemen
die Putin hat also wir haben gerade
schon darüber gesprochen dass das
narrativ dass er so gerne benutzt
schwierig werden könnte für ihn
zunehmend also vor allem eben auch das
dass es sich gar nicht um den Krieg
handeln würde das würde in der Tat wohl
nicht mehr lange aufrechterhalten können
in den russischen Propaganda Medien ist
ja in den letzten Tagen schon zu
beobachten gewesen dass dort offen von
Krieg gesprochen wurde es wird jetzt
behauptet es sei ein Krieg Russlands
gegen den gesamten Westen und deshalb
deswegen so schwierig weil man es nicht
nur mit der Ukraine zu tun hätte sondern
mit der gesamten NATO und der westlichen
Welt also das sind Propaganda
Erzählungen die dort jetzt sehr stark
verbreitet werden die glaube ich aber
auch nicht dazu beitragen dass jetzt
viele Russen sich in die Schlange
stellen und sagen ich möchte da
unbedingt mitkämpfen in diesem Krieg
Putins und das ist ja schon eine
Besonderheit dass viele Russen diesen
Krieg zwar unterstützt haben aber immer
unter der Bedingung dass sie ihn selbst
nicht führen müssen und jetzt wird diese
Frage eben an die Russen gestellt sind
Sie bereit auch dafür zu kämpfen für die
Ziele die Putin da ausgerufen hat und
das ist ganz offensichtlich nicht der
Fall jetzt sprechen wir also von
sozusagen Druck der entstehen könnte von
Seiten der Opposition aber es gibt ja
auch noch anderen Druck der auf Putin
aufgebaut führt nämlich den der
Nationalisten die ja teilweise sogar
eine general mobil machen also eine noch
drastischere Maßnahme gefordert haben
wie würden Sie putinsituationen
eingeklemmt sozusagen zwischen diesen
beiden Lagern beschreiben
Putin hat sich in einer
Ecke manövriert aus der er aus meiner
Sicht nicht mehr hinaus kommen kann er
hat eine militärische Operation begonnen
die er
wo er keine seiner Ziele bisher
erreichen konnte wo Russland extrem hohe
Verluste hinnehmen muss und wo ganz
offensichtlich die Annahmen die zu der
Entscheidung geführt haben jetzt diesen
Krieg zu führen falsch gewesen sind und
nicht nur dass die Ziele nicht erreicht
wurden jetzt sind sogar große Gebiete
zurückerobert worden und die Ukrainer
werden jetzt ja nicht nach den
Erklärungen von heute auf ihren Händen
sitzen bleiben die werden ja weiter
kämpfen und weiter Angriffe gegen die
Russen organisieren also da hat er ein
ganz großes Problem und er wird
natürlich aber auch von ganz rechts von
den Nationalisten unter Druck gesetzt
jetzt soll er doch wirklich mal ernst
machen und mit der General
immobiliemachung und mit brutalsten
Einsatz von Gewalt die Sache entscheiden
aber ich glaube die auch die
Nationalisten überschätzen da die
russischen militärischen Möglichkeiten
aber Putin hat der Geister geweckt die
er jetzt nicht mehr eingehegt bekommt
und hat offensichtlich da jetzt
nachgeben müssen gegenüber den Militärs
und den Nationalisten zumindest mit
dieser timurmobil-machung und
gleichzeitig weiß er ganz genau dass
insbesondere die Bevölkerung in den
großen Städten die North carot in Moskau
in St Petersburg
keine Lust darauf hat ihre Söhne ihre
Väter ihre Brüder in diesen Krieg zu
schicken das ist ja aus den Beiträgen
die man heute schon bei ihnen gesehen
hat sehr deutlich geworden
und das wird jetzt interessant sein wie
lang eigentlich die Halbwertszeit ist
von den Entscheidungen die Putin da
getroffen hat wenn er von beiden Seiten
so stark unter Druck steht wir haben die
Bilder für hin gesehen von der Grenze zu
Finland wo sich teilweise die Autos
schon stauen es ist auch zu lesen von
einem absoluten Run auf Flugtickets die
Preise in bestimmte Orte sollen sich
verzehnfacht haben teilweise oder noch
mehr also ein sehr begehrtes guten
momentan oder der Versuch jedenfalls
auch zahlreich aus dem Land sich
abzusetzen und nicht zu vergessen das
ist ja schon zehntausende Russinnen und
Russen Präsident die seit Beginn des
Krieges das Land verlassen haben wie
schätzen Sie das ein wird sich dieser
Exodus jetzt weiter verstärken
ja das hängt davon ab wie stark der
Repressionsapparat noch funktioniert und
wie sehr man die Leute zwingen kann
jetzt in die Streitkräfte zu kommen aber
das ganze zeigt doch das Ausmaß des
Zynismus nicht nur bei Putin und seiner
Clique sondern generell auch in der
russischen Gesellschaft also für für
Putin und seine Leute ist das in Ordnung
wenn viele
zehntausende russische Soldaten wenn sie
aus marginalisierten Gruppen kommen wenn
sie sterben und offensichtlich für viele
Bürger in St Petersburg und in Moskau
waren die Grausamkeiten gegen die
Ukraine und die vielen Toten russischen
Soldaten aus dem fernen Osten bisher
auch kein Problem aber jetzt wenn sie
selbst betroffen sind dann ändert sich
plötzlich die Lage und es gab ja finde
ich ganz aufschlussreich heute eine
Aussage des Sohns des Pressesprechers
von Herrn Putin von Herrn teskow der von
Menschen angerufen worden ist die so
getan haben als seien sie
dazu beauftragt ihn jetzt einzuziehen zu
Truppe wo er gesagt hat also er hätte da
andere Möglichkeiten und er würde nicht
zu den Streitkräften gehen also selbst
die die am meisten hetzen für diesen
Krieg sind gar nicht bereit diesen Krieg
selbst zu führen also dieser zynische
Widerspruch der wird jetzt einfach
offengelegt
ja das ist zum einen war zum anderen
wollte ich sie noch nach was anderem
fragen wenn wir die Position der
Bundesregierung bzw darauf können wir
vielleicht gleich noch mal zu sprechen
kommen
zunächst vielleicht noch ganz dafür oder
zunächst die Frage nach Putin er hat
sich ja dafür entschieden die wir hatten
das gerade schon gesagt die Reservisten
zu aktivieren das ist in den Augen
manche ein Zeichen der Schwäche sie
hatten dafür auch schon ihre Kommentare
zu abgegeben manche wiederum erwarten
ist von ihm wir hatten gesagt er ist da
ein bisschen eingeklemmt zwischen diesen
beiden Lagern und wir hatten jetzt eben
gerade auch noch mal gesagt dass es eben
eine ganze Reihe von Menschen gibt die
das Land schon verlassen wollen und wenn
ich da jetzt gerade noch mal ansetzen
darf das sind ja in der Regel dann doch
Leute die wahrscheinlich auch besser
ausgebildet sind höher qualifiziert sind
was könnte das auch für die russische
Gesellschaft bedeuten
ich habe heute eine
Statistik gelesen die vermutlich gar
nicht so falsch ist weil sie vom FSB
also vom russischen Inlandsgeheimdienst
selbst veröffentlicht wurde das etwa 4
Millionen russische Staatsbürger
Russland verlassen haben seit dem
Februar
das hat mit dem Klick zu tun das hat
aber auch damit zu tun dass es System
sich von einem autoritären zu einem
totalitären System verändert hat seit
Februar und das viele Menschen in
Russland einfach überhaupt gar keine
Zukunft mehr sehen und dass ich
Hoffnungslosigkeit breit gemacht hat
insbesondere ja auch unter dem besser
ausgebildeten und jüngeren Menschen die
ja viele von denen zumindest die ja
leben wollen wie wie wir auch leben die
sich selbst verwirklichen wollen und das
ist natürlich für die russische
Gesellschaft fatal wenn die gut
ausgebildeten und klugen Menschen das
Land verlassen ob es jetzt noch einen
weiteren Exodus geben kann das ist eine
offene Frage was ja wenig Möglichkeiten
gibt aus Russland überhaupt auszureisen
wenig Flugverbindungen gibt und die
wenigen Möglichkeiten die es gibt haben
sie gesagt die Grenzen nach Finnland
oder nach Belarus da gibt es jetzt Staus
und und Schwierigkeiten da überhaupt
rauszukommen
klar ist auch die Reservisten die
besondere Spezialitäten spezielle
Ausbildungen haben meditärische die sind
jetzt besonders begehrt und die werden
glaube ich alles tun um zu versuchen
diesen Ruf zu entgehen und das ist ja
schon seit vielen Jahren in Kennzeichen
Russlands das nur die in den
Streitkräften laden die niemand landen
die niemanden bestechen können die
niemanden kennt in der Beziehungen hat
die sich also nicht wehren können in
diesem korrupten System die wird es dann
am Ende treffen und die müssen dann in
diesen Krieg ziehen und es gibt noch
einen weiteren Punkt es gibt viele
Hinweise darauf dass Unternehmen
Deckmantel dieser thaimobilmachung jetzt
auch Wehrpflichtige von denen man immer
gesagt hat sie werden nicht in den Krieg
geschickt Wehrpflichtige an die Front
gebracht werden sollen da gibt es
Berichte aus St Petersburg und auch aus
anderen Städten und das verändert die
Lage natürlich auch noch mal sehr
telefonmann fragt uns über Youtube es
scheint als wird Putins Krieg in
Russland jeden Tag unterstützt sowohl
von der Bevölkerung als auch von
politischen Kreisen erhöht das die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Putsches gegen
ihn
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Putsches und
das ist ja die Gefahr die Putin sieht
von ganz rechts wird glaube ich vor
allen Dingen dadurch erhöht das Putin
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnt
also er hat nationalistische Kräfte in
seinem Nacken die wollen dass er alles
tut um die Ukraine zu vernichten und die
ihnen sozusagen für einen Schwächling
halten dass er das nicht hinbekommt und
und da hat er glaube ich den
allergrößten Druck im Moment und musste
deswegen auch dieser tarnoviermachung
nachgeben also das sind nicht unbedingt
Leute die gegen den Krieg sind da sind
auch viele Leute die wollen es
eigentlich noch schlimmer die ihn jetzt
unter Druck setzen
ja kleinen Moment ganz kurz jawohl da
sind wir wieder an der richtigen Stelle
ich muss immer versuchen hier die Fragen
unserer User mit dem abzugleichen was
Sie mir sagen und das ist manchmal gar
nicht so einfach ich wollte vorhin schon
das hatte ich vorhin angekündigt mit
ihnen sprechen über die Position der
Bundesregierung ist das nicht jetzt auch
sozusagen eine Form von Eskalation die
da gerade stattfindet die man ja
eigentlich vermeiden wollte deswegen ja
auch die relative Zurückhaltung der
Bundesregierung bislang wenn es zum
Beispiel ging um die Frage der Lieferung
von Kampfpanzern was bedeutet das jetzt
also diese mobil machen diese teilmobil
machen für die deutsche Position
erwarten Sie da größere Anpassungen
dazu zunächst mal ist es doch so durch
diese Erklärung der Teilmobilmachung und
durch die neuen Gesetze und die Drohung
die Putin ausgesprochen hat hat sich
doch militärisch an der Lage in der
Ukraine nichts geändert also insofern
ist es eine verbale Eskalation aber da
ist glaube ich die richtige Haltung und
das hat man glaube ich in Europa in der
ganzen Welt heute auch gesehen sich
nicht einschüchtern zu lassen putin will
uns Angst machen putin will uns
einschüchtern das ist glaube ich das
Ziel dieser ganzen Aktion der letzten
beiden Tage und ich glaube die beste
Reaktion darauf ist gelassen zu bleiben
und in Ruhe das zu tun was ja dazu
beigetragen hat das Putin jetzt so
schwach ist nämlich die Ukraine
systematisch zu unterstützen und die
Ukraine so stark zu machen dass sie
diesen Krieg beenden kann ich glaube das
ist der beste Weg
der Politikwissenschaftler und Russland
Experte Niko lange war das für uns
vielen Dank für das Gespräch danke schön
und wir kommen noch mal explizit zum
militärischen Aspekt der teilmobil
machen denn auch darstellen sich jetzt
natürlich fragen zum Beispiel ob denn
die russische Armee noch über
ausreichend Material verfügt nachdem in
den vergangenen Tagen und Wochen ja
gerade im Zuge der ukrainischen
Gegenoffensive da wollten wir eigentlich
noch ein paar Bilder zeigen ja einiges
zerstört oder zurückgelassen wurde da
sehen wir genau Panzer die teilweise
noch völlig intakt sind wie lange dürfte
es dauern bis die Reservisten
tatsächlich dann auch kampfbereit sind
von 300.000 war ja mal die Rede bzw ist
heute die Rede und das sind Fragen über
die wir jetzt unter anderem sprechen
wollen mit dem Militärexperten von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik er ist
außerdem oberster.de einen schönen guten
Abend Wolfgang Richter schön dass Sie
wieder bei uns sind hallo
schönen guten Abend herr Werner also
300.000 Reservisten sollen die russische
Armee verstärken wie schätzen Sie diese
Entscheidung ganz allgemein ein ja es
ist zunächst einmal ein Eingeständnis
dass die militärische Lage für Russland
im Moment sehr kritisch ist die
Kräfteansatz war von vornherein zu
gering man hat wohl geglaubt dass ich
die Dinge so wiederholen werden wie 2014
dass die Ukraine nicht kämpfen werden
oder nur ein kleiner Teil oder
vielleicht freiwilliger aber das sind
Teil der aktiven Kräfte sogar überläufig
das in der auf der Grimm der Fall war
das alles war eine eklatante
Fehleinschätzung der widerstandswelle
der Ukraine hat sich seitdem ungeheuer
gefestigt und wir sehen ja die
Ergebnisse
vor Kiew konnte man den Niederlage
vielleicht noch damit begründen dass
diese Leistung der Ukraine völlig
unterschätzt worden ist in hakiff sieht
das anders aus nach 6 Monaten Krieg kann
man sagen die ukrainische
Führungsfähigkeit ist überlegen die
Flexibilität ist überlegen haben die
russische Führung ist nicht besonders
eindrucksvoll und die
koordinierungsfähigkeit ist sicherlich
nicht das was Putin sich vorgestellt hat
oder was auch im Westen
Militärexperten vermutet haben die
Verluste sind sehr hoch das gilt sowohl
für personalverluste als auch für
Materialverluste und mit diesen Kräften
die jetzt vor Ort hat das sind immerhin
schon 60 Prozent aller Landstreitkräfte
die mittlerweile gebunden sind in der
Ukraine wird er keine durchschlagenden
weiteren Erfolge mehr erzählen er
braucht Reserven das tut er jetzt er hat
300.000 Mann also einberufen zu den
Fahnen aber es wird dauern denn so
schnell können die ja gar nicht an der
Front sein und sie müssen erst mal
ausgebildet ausgerüstet werden in
Strukturen eingebaut werden und dann an
die Front gebracht werden das dauert
zwei bis drei Monate ich glaube nicht
dass das sehr viel schneller geht
andernfalls würde man erneut ein Risiko
eingehen mit nicht gut vorbereitenden
organisierten Truppen letztlich dann
weiter Verluste einzufahren ja Herr
Richter jetzt haben sie schon ein paar
Fakten sozusagen vorweggenommen nachdem
ich sie noch fragen wollte machen was
noch ein bisschen der der Reihenfolge
genau das macht ja gar nichts äh ich
lese gerade noch mal einen Kommentar vor
von Arnold a Lampe die drei wichtigsten
Komponenten einer erfolgreichen
Kriegsführung schreibt er sind
logistikkoordination und Kommunikation
das russische Militär russische Militär
hat Defizite bei allen drei Reservisten
werden daran nichts ändern das ist seine
Einschätzung und dann haben wir noch
eine Frage von Captain Nemo auch über
YouTube in den Medien wird berichtet die
300.000 sollen Kampf erprobte
Reservisten sein woher kommen die denn
und wie will man eine spezialoperation
mit einer teilmobilenmachung verkaufen
zunächst einmal diese erste Bewertung
kann ich teilen also die
Führungsfähigkeit ist sehr schlecht die
logistische Vorbereitung war schlecht
und vor allem die Fähigkeit zu
koordinieren das heißt also das Gefecht
verbundene Waffen zu führen oder auch
verbundene Operationen wenn man die
Luftstreitkräfte jetzt mit einbezieht zu
führen ist tatsächlich unterentwickelt
da hätte man mehr erwartet auch von der
Luftstreitkräften wir im Verhältnis von
zehn zu eins nach wenn es nach dem
Waffensystem geht überlegen sind dann
noch haben sie nicht die Leistung
gezeigt die man erwartet hätte ich
vermute auch dass zunächst mal der Luft
kriegt jetzt verstärkt wird denn bis die
Reservisten dann in organisierten
Strukturen an der Front erscheinen
können wird es noch dauern das wird in
den Winter hineingehen und das bedeutet
wir müssen erstmal damit rechnen dass
die Luftstreitkräfte ihren Krieg
intensivieren vor allen Dingen gegen die
Infrastruktur die
Energieproduktion die Bahnlinien denn
die ukrainische Bahn ist ja wichtig für
die Logistik aber auch für das
Verbringen von
und sie ist elektrifiziert also hier
können wir diese ersten Schritte jetzt
erwarten insofern teile ich also die
Einschätzung durchaus ob das alles sich
jetzt ändert weil 300.000 Reservisten
kommen wird man sehen aber wir können
auch verstellen dass diese Reservisten
aus ehemaligen aktiven Soldaten also sei
es wehrpflichte aber vor allen Dingen
aus kontraktsoldaten also aus wir würden
sagen salzsoldaten bestehen die jetzt
vor einigen Jahren gedient haben die
natürlich erstmal wieder eine
Ergänzungsausbildung brauchen und dann
in ihre Strukturen eingeordnet werden
müssen bevor sie an der Front verfügbar
sind ich glaube schon dass hier
entsprechend Kräfte generiert werden
können zum Material und zu den
Strukturen die Russen verfügen noch über
etwa 35
Brigaden die als
immobilienmachungsbrigaden deklariert
sind und haben auch noch erhebliche
waffenbestände in den Depots allerdings
sind diese waffenbestände ältere Art sie
sind nicht die modernsten Typen aber gut
wir gehen also bis T-72 oder dergleichen
wenn man auf Kampfpanzer sieht und ich
vermute mal dass sie auch nicht in guten
Zustand sind also man wird auch viele
Waffensysteme erstmal instand setzen
müssen bevor man sie dann ihr wirklich
einsetzen kann all das dauert Zeit das
wird Zeit brauchen neben der Ankündigung
der Mobilmachung ist ja vor allem die
indirekte Drohung mit Atomwaffen heute
aufhören auf horchen wir hören noch mal
rein in die Rede von Präsident Putin
auch die atomare Erpressung hat jetzt
begonnen ich spreche nicht nur von dem
vom Westen geförderten Beschuss des
atomkraftwerksaporicia durch den eine
nukleare Katastrophe droht sondern auch
von den Äußerungen einiger hochrangiger
Vertreter führender NATO-Länder ob es
möglich und zulässig ist
Massenvernichtungswaffen also Atomwaffen
gegen Russland einzusetzen
diejenigen die sich solche Äußerungen
gegenüber Russland erlauben möchte ich
daran erinnern dass auch unser Land über
verschiedene zerstörungsmittel verfügt
von denen einige Komponenten
fortschrittlicher sind als die der
NATO-Länder wenn die territoriale
Integrität unseres Landes bedroht ist
werden wir natürlich alle uns zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel einsetzen um
Russland und unser Volk zu verteidigen
dies ist kein Bluff
notfalls werde man also alle zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel einsetzen was
ja dann eben auch Atomwaffen mit
einschließen würde und explizit sagte
wir haben es gerade gehört dass sei kein
Bluff was ist davon zu halten ja
zunächst mal kenne ich persönlich keine
Äußerungen aus westlichem Munde also
jedenfalls von Verantwortlichen die
Russland mit dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen
gedroht haben meistens ist es umgekehrt
dass man Drohungen die aus der
russischen Seite kommen oder die man als
solcher interpretiert dann entsprechend
kommentiert und man warnt ja beiden hat
das also Präsident beiden hat das ja
kürzlich gemacht dreimal hat er
wiederholt tu das nicht setzt keine
Massenvernichtungswaffen ein ja was ist
davon zu halten es gibt da vielleicht
drei Antworten darauf das eine das ist
die Frage macht es einen Sinn taktische
Atomwaffen in der Ukraine einzusetzen
ich glaube das wäre völlig irrational es
würde ja auch die eigenen Truppen
treffen es würde
Wirkungen haben die gar nicht
kontrollieren kann wegen der abdriften
wegen der radioaktiven Verseuchung die
er auch durch die Winde mitgebet wird es
würde auch die Bevölkerung treffen die
man jetzt ja per Referent um zu Russen
machen will also es macht alles
überhaupt keinen Sinn es ist irrational
der zweite Punkt ist wenn sich das
Ausweiten sollte und man ein Szenario
eines nuklearen Austausches mit der NATO
hat dann kann man nur sagen dann gilt
das was alle Atomwaffen starten Anfang
Januar gemeinsam bei der UNO noch
verkündet haben ein Atomkrieg kann nicht
gewonnen werden er darf nie geführt
werden es gibt hier so viele
gegenseitige zerstörungskräfte das auch
das völlig irrational wäre und drittens
wenn einer das nukleare Tabu das ja seit
1945 seit hiroshimaanlage besteht bricht
dann ist er der geächtete der Outcast
der von allen isoliert wird und er wird
keine Verbündeten mehr haben das gilt
dann auch für denjenigen die jetzt schon
vorsichtige absatzbewegungen machen also
ich nehme mal vor einigen China an das
überhaupt kein Interesse daran hat dass
die Dinge aus dem Ruder laufen und dass
die Welt sich destabilisiert über
Nuklearwaffen Einsätze dann wird man
allenfalls noch Leute wie äh
kim Jong um an der Seite haben aber das
ist das Ende einer diplomatischen oder
irgendeiner Integration in eine
Weltgemeinschaft und wir sollten nicht
vergessen dass die Antwort des Westens
hier ziemlich hart sein dürfte ja also
sie halten es für wenig wahrscheinlich
für wenig wahrscheinlich aus ähnlichen
Gründen hält es auch Ben Hodges es geht
um den Einsatz eben der Atomwaffen das
hat der ehemalige US-General und
ehemalige Oberkommandeur für die
US-Streitkräfte in Europa und letzten
Freitag gesagt das wollen wir uns gerade
auch noch mal anhören
wenn Russland eine taktische
Nuklearwaffe in der Ukraine benutzt dann
wäre es für die USA und das Vereinigte
Königreich unmöglich nicht zu reagieren
der Kreml will nicht dass die USA direkt
in diesen Krieg involviert werden das
hätte ganz schlimme Auswirkungen für die
russischen Kräfte die amerikanische
Antwort wäre nicht unbedingt eine
nukleare Reaktion sie würden vielleicht
Luftangriffe fliegen oder
Marschflugkörper einsetzen sie würden
das was von der Schwarzmeerflotte übrig
ist zerstören genau wie die russischen
Basen auf der Krim und im Don Bass der
Kreml weiß das ich glaube auch dass
Putin nicht verrückt ist er ist böse
aber nicht verrückt ich glaube auch
nicht dass die Leute um ihn herum
verrückt sind und aus diesen Gründen
glaube ich nicht dass sie eine Atomwaffe
einsetzen werden
ja böse aber nicht verrückt so die
Einschätzung von Herrn Hottes aber
würden sie ihm zumindest in dem Punkt
zustimmen dass Putin dann doch in dem
Falle dann rational genug ist um eben
genau diesen Schritt an diesen letzten
nicht zu gehen absolut also ich meine
das oberste Interesse das Putin haben
muss ist selbst zu überleben mit seinem
politischen Regime und auch Russland als
Ganzes die Wirtschaft Russlands und die
Stellung Russlands nicht zu gefährden er
hat es bisher sehr weit getrieben das
muss man sagen er beginnt jetzt
Verbündete zu verlieren aber dieser
Schritt wäre völlig irrational ich
glaube das wird Putin nicht tun
jawohl wenn wir jetzt die atomare
Komponente noch mal außen vor lassen und
noch mal auf die mobilwachung mobil
machen zu sprechen kommen wie schätzen
sie dann Russlands verbliebenes
Potenzial an Waffen ein wenn wir mal
sprechen über die 300.000 Reservisten
die müssten ja dann auch noch bewaffnet
und ausgerüstet werden in eine ähnliche
Richtung fragt uns auch Alexander g über
youtube ist das nicht ein logistischer
Albtraum wenn Russland jetzt daran oder
dann noch 300.000 Mal mehr zu versorgen
habt hat sie haben sich ja in diesem
Punkt auch bislang nicht mit Ruhm
bekleckert
ja sie haben sich in der operativen
Versorgung nicht mit unbekleckert aber
wir sollten nicht unterschätzen was in
den russischen Depots noch an Material
liegt ich hatte ja schon darauf
hingewiesen dass das sehr umfangreich
ist es ist zwar älteres Material aber in
einem Gefecht verbundenen Waffen zählt
natürlich am Ende auch die Zahl und die
Quantität ist bedeutend ob die das
hinbekommen in kurzer Zeit diese
Materiallager und die Reservisten und
die entsprechenden Strukturen so
zusammenzuführen dass daraus
kampfkräftige Verbände entstehen das
muss man abwarten es bestehen zumindest
35 Rahmen Strukturen für privaten die
noch da sind die kann man auffüllen ich
vermute auch das Russland immer wieder
so etwas trainiert hat das ist nicht so
ganz anders als es im Kalten Krieg auch
in der Bundeswehr war aber das ist
natürlich ein großer Aufwand das sind
riesen Entfernung zu überwinden ob sie
es logistisch hinkriegen kann man
natürlich nach den ersten Ergebnissen
der letzten sechs Monate in der Ukraine
bezweifeln aber es wird da schon was
ankommen ich glaube schon dass da eine
größere Masse zusammengebracht wird mit
der die Russen dann versuchen werden die
Initiative wieder an sich zu reißen
ja uns erreichen gerade ich schaue hier
immer mit einem Auge auf die Agenturen
Meldungen dass bis zu 800 Personen wohl
jetzt festgenommen worden sein sollen
bei Demonstrationen in Russland also da
geht das Regime mit der Härte vor mit
aller Härte die es hat das haben wir
vorhin in den Nachrichten auch schon
gesehen bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei
der Teilmobilmachung uns fragt Norbert
Kranz über Youtube sollten die Balken
Polen etc jetzt nicht auch Teil
mobilisieren sicher ist sicher
also ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt im
Moment der entscheidende Punkt ist man
muss sich vorbereiten auf alle eventuell
Fälle das ist richtig
man wird man hat ja solche Übungen immer
schon durchgeführt das ist nichts Neues
man muss dazu bereit sein das jetzt zu
tun hatte ich für falsch weil das würde
eine weitere Eskalationsstufe bedeuten
im Moment sehen wir auch gar kein
Schwerpunkt an der baltischen Grenze
nehmen Sie mal die Luft landete Vision
vom scuf das ist direkt an der
baltischen Grenze die hat man
mittlerweile dort mit großer Masse
abgezogen und in der Ukraine eingesetzt
also auch dort wird deutlich oder
Unterschied zwischen Rhetorik ist und
zwischen der wirklichen Schwerpunkt und
wo es brennt ist eben die Ukraine aus
russischer Sicht und ich glaube das ist
da keine weitere Eskalation geben kann
jedenfalls nicht mit Landstreitkräften
was Luftstreitkräfte betrifft sieht das
ein bisschen anders aus die
luftstrahlkräfte haben noch freie
Kapazitäten sie sind noch nicht in
vollem Umfang eingesetzt worden das kann
noch kommen deswegen vermute ich auch
uns zunächst einmal als erster Schritt
ist diese Reserven verfügbar sind von
dem wir gesprochen haben die
Luftstreitkräfte den Luftkrieg
intensivieren werden und die kritische
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine angreifen
werden da sprechen wir auch noch mal
über die vier scheinreferenten die jetzt
anstehen mit denen also jetzt möglichst
schnell noch in den nächsten Tagen
Anschluss der vier besetzten Gebiete im
Osten und im Süden der Ukraine an
Russland hergestellt werden soll welche
militärischen Auswirkungen hätte das
also wenn jetzt die Ukraine Ziele dort
beschießen würde würde Russland würde
Moskau das dann quasi wie einen Angriff
auf eigenes Staatsgebiet dann betrachten
also das ist offenbar die Absicht dass
man ein Gebiet annektiert es
anschließend also zur russischen
Territorium erklärt und dann behauptet
man habe russisches Territorium
angegriffen aber das ist natürlich eine
Legende die ich glaube weltweit niemand
Putin abnehmen wird und es geht hier
schlichtweg um eine Annexion das ist
ganz offensichtlich ein solches re ist
ein Fake es ist überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet die Bevölkerung ist zum Teil
nicht da zum Teil ist das Ganze zerstört
die Kontrolle liegt natürlich auf der
russischen Seite was kann man alles
manipulieren eine internationale
Überwachung gibt es ohnehin nicht und
vor allen Dingen gibt es keine
völkerrechtliche Begründung für so ein
Referendum ist seine schlechte Annexion
eines Territoriums eines Nachbarstaates
der Souverän ist und der natürlich
Anspruch hat auf der Rituale Integrität
aber auch auf Verteidigung und damit
auch auf die kollektive Verteidigung
also sprich auch auf die Hilfe aus
anderen Staaten letzte Frage nochmal an
den Militärexperten müsste Deutschland
gerade jetzt Kampfpanzer liefern bevor
sozusagen Fakten beschaffen werden denn
in den letzten Tagen hatte man ja
durchaus den Eindruck dass die Ukraine
und nicht nur den Eindruck des wirel de
facto so Geländegewinne erzielen kann
wie würden sie da momentan die
militärische Situation bewerten stehen
dass wir die ukrainische Armee nicht
unterschätzen sollten sie waren von
Anfang an sehr stark sie haben über
1.100 Kampfpanzer gehabt am 24 Februar
waren damit die zweitstärkste Armee in
Europa ohne also wenn ich jetzt nicht
die Türkei mit rechne und das ist
viermal so viel wie die Bundeswehr im
aktiven Bestand hat und natürlich sind
die Verluste auch teilweise ersetzt
worden die Verluste waren auch bei den
Ukrainern hoch das ist richtig aber was
wir bei diesen Angriffen jetzt gesehen
haben ist dass es vor allen Dingen
darauf ankommt die russische Taktik zu
unterminieren die ja darauf beruht dass
man selbst nur angreifen kann wenn man
mit erheblicher Artillerie Vorbereitung
mit großer Konzentration von Artillerie
auf engen Räumen arbeitet und die
Artillerie des also die Lieferungen des
Westens ziehen ja genau darauf ab mit
großer Präzision und großer Reichweite
ein Gegenfeuer eine
gegenfeuermöglichkeit zu schaffen und
die war offenbar sehr erfolgreich und
ich glaube an der Stelle sollten wir
auch einiges noch noch mehr tun und der
nächste Punkt der jetzt glaube ich
anliegt das ist die Luftverteidigung die
gestärkt werden muss denn ich vermute
dass die Russen ihre Luftangriffe jetzt
verstärken
bisher waren sie noch nicht so
überzeugend aber sie haben hier freie
Kapazitäten und die Luftverteidigung
wird sicherlich sehr wichtig werden dann
nehme ich noch eine user-frage dazu zur
Gismo fragt uns über Youtube wenn
Russland jetzt offiziell Krieg führt
bislang ist es ja nicht der Fall also
nach russischer Leser hat jedenfalls
nicht schätzen Sie dass die Ukraine dann
auch russische Städte angreift bis jetzt
hat sich die Ukraine in Russland selbst
ja sehr zurückgehalten
also nach dem Völkerrecht sind sie
natürlich berechtigt so etwas zu tun
also nicht Städte im eigentlichen Sinne
anzugreifen aber militärische Ziele
wenn um sich zu wehren gegen den
Angreifer dieses wäre eine weitere
Eskalationsstufe die auch im Westen
kritisch gesehen wird wir wissen dass
auch Präsident beiden die Sorge vor der
Eskalation durchaus hat er hat ja den
Ukrainern nicht die langstreckenmunition
für heimas gegeben sondern eben nur die
kürzere Reichweite von 80 km und hat
sich auch dabei noch versprechen lassen
dass sie nicht über die russischen
Grenzen schießen ich glaube diese
Bedenken noch weiter Öl ins Feuer zu
gießen und weiter zu eskalieren die gibt
es natürlich auf allen also auf
westlicher Seite nicht nur auf deutscher
Seite und deswegen halte ich es auch für
richtig solche Dinge nur in Abstimmungen
Bündnispartnern zu tun und die Risiken
gemeinsam einzuschätzen
also einige Fragen konnten wir
beantworten andere bleiben naturgemäß
offen ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich das
war der Militärexperte Wolfgang Richter
von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik Dankeschön und einen schönen
Abend ansehen gerne Herr Wehrmann Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend danke schön und
auch euch vielen Dank wie immer für euer
Interesse fürs Mitmachen ich wünsche
euch auch einen schönen Abend und sage
danke und bis zum nächsten Mal ciao ciao